are you evolving could cartographers
just now okay now this interesting this
is still not the heading cartography is
nothing I love to do so my class all the
time I say you know I lose engine public
okay and I dislike giving the solutions
quickly because then if you ever problem
and get solved for you very fast it's
kind of like you never get to struggle
with it and you don't learn very much
from it so the way I said to my classes
is I um I let it simmer I let it simmer
so it's like a little problem sitting in
your head now here's what's really
interesting to me everyone was okay with
three colors
I mean Australia which three colors no
problems okay so you could have made one
just like Australia we're gonna let you
are okay with four colors as well I saw
lots of beautiful four color maps so you
go from here
no big deal but then even with some
fantastically complicated maths I have
yet I'm yet to see a map that requires
five colors and people came to me and
said here's a five color bat and every
single one I've been presented with so
far I've been able to color with four
colors now here's the thing is they
they're for a second cuz we're gonna man
out of time and I would love for you
guys to see the whole point is this
sound this is a map of Europe people who
a good photographer could help me with
this and this is most obvious one going
up Switzerland going up Czech Republic
Austria and hungry good okay now
all right I'll come down we're getting a
second color this woman's color with me
how many do we need
why don't me to color Jemmy no it's not
clearly clearly mr. Easton what should
be my next red country Italy okay
next can I color any more red all right
what should I start with Poland what
next can I do any more in green yes
there's all the essence let's make all
the answers blue and then my last one
for now I dunno I didn't design this map
this is actually Europe right now this
is very interesting you've designed maps
the world has maps and they all seem to
cap off at four colors okay why is this
this is mysteriously this by the way
this is your heading if you want to put
one in now the heading is the four color
theorem you see now you see why I
couldn't name it before right the
theorem is no matter what map you
present so long as it's in two days okay
um you don't ever need more than four
colors to color it never ever now if you
have a coloring for it I can suggest a
different coloring with just four colors
okay we're just for now don't forget we
don't mind points its borders its
borders the closet problem now really
really interesting
it was 1852 1852 when this for color
theorem was proposed it's very very it's
intensely interesting for two reasons
number one it got proposed in 1852 how
long do you think it took them like
people or draw maps for a long time
right how long do you think it took them
to prove this tip as we put it what
would you get it doesn't seem
complicated like it's not like it's
enough seventeen color theorem right it
doesn't seem like it's that big a deal
guess how long more than more than a
hundred years it took more than a
hundred years okay so there's the first
interesting thing remember I said think
deeply that simple things right this is
simple and you can make up even simpler
ones secondly how do they do it this was
the first first no exceptions
major mathematical proof that was proven
with computers and as a result people
rejected they said this is not a proof
right I can't see the logic a computers
done it
I disagree okay lots of people disagree
with them for many years
now the question is why why is it true
okay well here's what I'm gonna suggest
and let you have a think oh there's my
final party feel free okay have a look
at this map over here how many colors
can we do it here well already based on
this you already have a number let's
just try it out okay I'm gonna do it in
a particular way I'm going to do it like
this
I would call beyond sorry I'm gonna do
this one green okay now have a look at
this map with me again another four
color map but here's the important thing
I know it doesn't look like it but maybe
you can tell by the way that I slowly
went about it
this map is Europe okay now on what
basis do I justify this year well let's
think about this
have a look at the map that I drew now a
lot of you guys drew maps with just
straight lines just straight lines right
now I know this looks more mappy cuz you
know it's all jagged stuff but like if I
straightened out some of these borders I
straightened out the board it wouldn't
matter it wouldn't change the problem I
straighten this out they still have to
be different colors and if I straighten
this out and on own if I straighten them
all out you end here okay same
arrangement of colors okay so we have a
word for this we call these two maps
homeomorphic this is important where you
should get it down okay what it means
that is that you remember in u7 we had a
look at transformations to know the
transformations there are three kinds of
transformations do you remember what
they are
see if you're as a class I'm sure we
came up yeah one turning so that would
be rotation yeah okay give me another
one reflection that's flipping and
translation what's translations it's
just yes okay so transit oh you mean
this I'm 20 seconds so transformations
means you can do all these three things
and it stays the same
Hermia move it means not a
transformation but a defamation you see
we've squeezed and we've squashed it and
stretched it out but it's still the same
map now this is simple you can see it
with this and any map like this only
four colors just one last pair of words
for you to get down you like this number
than hitting on geometry okay but this
idea here this idea of homeomorphic maps
deforming things and them still sustain
the same is not under geometry it's
under topic called topology right this
is the study of shapes that have to sort
of their region they have to stay put
but this is the study of spaces that can
be moved and shifted okay